german defence minister thomas de
Maiziere has long been one of Chancellor
Angela Merkel's inner circle one of her
most trusted cabinet members now his job
is on the line for something he says was
not his fault in summer 2011 de Maiziere
posed confidently with a model of what
was to be Germany's first surveillance
drone the euro hawk when the test
version was presented in Munich in late
2011 the builders were just as confident
they touted the euro hawk as the
multi-purpose surveillance craft of the
future damn it is design sets can be
deployed for natural disasters border
patrol operations maritime surveillance
chasing pirates and all kinds of
communications and security for major
events like soccer championships but
sauron it was me so many many potential
uses that go far beyond military wise
Schettino Fela unbending deal with the
military now scale but none of that is
any good if the Wonder drone isn't
approved for European airspace the
15-ton unmanned aircraft with a 35 meter
wingspan reportedly lacked an adequate
collision protection system and it would
cost too much to add one on the minister
scrap the whole project there by tossing
half a billion euros already spent on
development out the window when course
when cost threatened to get out of hand
like that we'd rather just pull the plug
in so good it may be a bit late for that
it seems the problems were already known
at its presentation in 2011 i'm usagi
upton it was definitely clear by late
2011 that could only get the approval if
costs of more than 600 million euros
were added then at the very latest the
minister should have pulled the plug and
not just let the problem slide for a
year and a half demacia has a reputation
for reliability thoroughness and
discipline he has stated that he looks
at both the whole picture and the fine
details so how did this detail slip past
due
Kurtis completes yet reality is a
complicated thing and the realities in
the field of military hardware are
especially complicated all the more
reason why we need a thorough and
objective accounting of the euro hawk
project and I've taken personal charge
of this task I'm sticking to my course
of action and soon I'll be reporting on
the entire development of this project
as far as I'm concerned there's nothing
more to say on the subject at the moment
in less than a week de Maiziere is to
appear before the defense committee
until then he has no comment meanwhile
the defence minister is feeling the
pressure stoffer because it does start
to listen can I think the criticism that
he of all people someone who's always
trying to do his job well and selflessly
has made various errors along the way
that's where it hurts the most whether
that turns out to be true remains to be
seen but i think the charge that he
acted carelessly or selfishly or
deliberately made mistakes as affected
him very deeply 15 teeth Chancellor
Merkel named de Maiziere adopter of law
as her chief of staff in 2005 at the
time she described him as one of her
oldest political friends in 2009 de
maizière was appointed interior minister
the position he'd been aiming for but in
2011 Chancellor Merkel needed a new
defence minister and tipped her old
friend for the job he hadn't wanted it
but he took on the task anyway and
towards the masseur shits I respect to a
must a museum not just for his brilliant
intellect and his exemplary sense of
duty and responsibility but above all
for his policymaking on the basis of
solid values his thinking starts with a
human being and he keeps his eye on
human beings on their problems and
concerns stop it I think he's where he
is because he's absolutely loyal and i
don't mean loyal in the cheap sense i
don't mean he never disagrees no matter
what i mean that he's decided this woman
is the Chancellor and I want to help her
be a success and so behind closed doors
I'll speak my mind openly and in public
i'll defend what we've agreed
on together as a matter of course in
this sense he plays a key role because
there aren't many left like Demacia has
appointed a 40-member task force from
his ministry to find out what exactly
went wrong on the Euro ho deal but the
opposition parties aren't willing to
wait for the results Marxist in knots
Oceanside shock were beginning to wonder
who is actually in charge of the Defense
Ministry if he needs 40 people to
investigate these urgent questions could
figure into zoo Humboldt you start
having doubts that the political
leadership is really in control of this
ministry ministerium the minister moods
the defense minister will be obliged to
break his oath of confidentiality when
he testifies to Parliament he has to
answer all the questions completely
given the amount of cash wasted there's
little chance they'll be satisfied with
a token apology one of the high flyers
in Merkel's cabinet is now hitting
turbulence the euro hawk has taken a hit
and might go down in flames the big
question now is will defense minister
tourmaster messy air crash and burn
right behind it